for years fans wondered exactly how much
of joss whedon's justice league was
original to his vision and how much he
took from zack snyder
now that the snyder cut of the film is
available on hbo max we have a much
better idea of exactly how much came
from each director
and the difference between the two is
striking in addition to numerous changes
in the narrative structure and character
development in zack snyder's justice
league the tone and feel of the two
films
is much different overall you can see
each director's signature style and it
seems pretty clear that in this case
most fans and critics agree zack
snyder's was a better fit to tell the
story
although the snyder cut is making a lot
of dc fans happy
there were some scenes in 2017's justice
league that were entertaining
and honestly kind of missed in the
unrelentingly bleak 2021 version
for example while barry allen remains
the primary source of comic relief in
the snyder cut
fans definitely noticed that many of his
most memorable moments from whedon's
version were left on the cutting room
floor
in some cases that was very much a good
thing did anyone really miss the cringy
moment when the flash face planted into
wonder woman's chest
however some of his throwaway lines did
add a bit of fun to justice league
like when he first saw the resurrected
superman that cemetery
the reference to stephen king's classic
novel didn't need much more than a name
drop because anyone who's read it or
seen the movie adaptations knows
it makes it very clear that when you
bring things back from the dead
sometimes they come back wrong
sometimes that is better barry's
reference while not exactly helpful in
the moment was both apt and amusing
there are so many stark differences
between the weed and cut and the snyder
cut that it's hard to keep track of them
but the ones that significantly change
the personality of the characters are
pretty hard to miss
one of these personality tweaks was on
display when the superhero's headed into
the tunnels
in the snyder cut the flash leaves a lot
of his dorkiness behind and shows
himself to be a more confident fighter
in whedon's justice league he has a
panicky moment when he confesses to
batman that he's not ready
to fight steppenwolf here's the thing um
see i'm afraid of bugs
and guns and obnoxiously tall people
it's funny sure but it's also one of the
few times that his role as a tension
breaker was used to reveal a bit more
about his vulnerabilities
we don't get to see a whole lot of
meta-humans acting vulnerable in
snyder's take
another downside to the change in
barry's trajectory here is that we
missed out on bruce advising him to
focus on saving one person
which marked a poignant moment of
mentorship between the two
speaking of the dark knight in many ways
the batman we meet in the snyder cut is
different from the one we saw in the
original theatrical version of justice
league
from beginning to end his story takes
different turns
both subtle and not so subtle and the
end result is a character who is even
more stoic than he was in the original
justice league
that means many of batman's jokes from
the weed and cut were not present in the
snyder cut
snyder's batman doesn't really do comedy
in some cases that's for the better but
his sense of humor was missed in the
scene where he takes the nightcrawler
out to dispatch some pair of demons
sorry guys i didn't bring a sword
of all the members of the justice league
aquaman definitely casts the most
intimidating shadow that's why the
moment in the weeden cut when he's
accidentally touching wonder woman's
infamous lasso of truth and begins to
confess that he's afraid of dying
was especially funny mamoa pulled the
moment off with gusto too
switching quickly from soft and mushy to
grumpy and threatening after he handed
the lasso back to diana
you say a word about this you'll meet
every prana i know so it's a bit
regrettable that this moment didn't make
it into the snyder cut though that's
likely because the director stuck to a
hard rule about removing all traces of
the wiedenesque
luckily we got to see plenty of aquaman
in the snyder cut so it more than made
up for this missing moment
and finally if anything highlights the
difference between the two director's
styles perfectly it's the difference
between those two epilogue scenes
arguably one of the more lighthearted
highlights from joss whedon's justice
league was the post-credits scene that
saw barry allen and clark kent preparing
for a friendly race to the pacific coast
does it add anything to the overall
story no not really but it does give us
a chance to see these two characters
banter and bond
it's not like a macho measuring thing
but if i win you're off the team
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the snyder cutter coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one